was hilft die jetzt gegen das virus
bayern verschärft die masken pflicht und
im ganzen land soll nach den hoch
ansteckenden varianten gefahndet werden
fake news im briefkasten mit
flugblättern wollen impfgegner corona
verharmlosen und die angst vor
impfstoffen schüren und kurzer prozess
auf der polizeiwache russland verurteilt
den kremlkritiker navalny zu 30 tagen
haft deutschland findet das vorgehen
völlig unhaltbar
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu einer neuen nachrichten
woche sport haben wir natürlich auch mit
norbert lehmann einen standort familie
es gibt vorsichtige hoffnungen in
deutschland scheinen die korona zahlen
zu sinken und die intensivstationen
melden eine leichte entspannung aber und
das ist das wohl entscheidende vor dem
corona gipfel morgen die
infektionszahlen sind nach wie vor viel
zu hoch und es droht gefahr durch
mutationen des virus sie könnten
erheblich ansteckender sein
axel konrad hat mehr corona ausbruch am
klinikum garmisch-partenkirchen 73
menschen infiziert viele davon mit einer
neuen womöglich bisher unbekannten virus
mutationen festgestellt im hauseigenen
labor was diese mutation für sich
alleine genommen bedeutet ist völlig
unklar
da ist es ganz wichtig die vollständige
sequenzierung abzuwarten
es untersucht die charité in berlin die
hoffnung ist groß dass die mutation
keine zusätzliche gefahr bringt denn der
blick auf die zahlen stimmt gerade mal
optimistisch 7141 neuinfektionen binnen
24 stunden so wenige wie seit monaten
nicht auch wenn er noch einige
nachmeldungen dazu komme der trend geht
offenbar in die richtige richtung die
zahlen sinken und die aktuellen
verschärfen zur zeit gültig sind
wir stehen ja erst seit montag letzter
woche die spiegelt sich in den zahlen
noch gar nicht so voll umfänglich wieder
und so entspannt sich auch die lage auf
den intensivstationen etwas weniger als
5000 betten belegt wichtig so die
mediziner denn ein anstieg der
patientenzahlen durch die virus
mutationen müsse einkalkuliert werden
beispiel großbritannien und irland dort
waren die zahlen zuletzt wieder
explosionsartig angestiegen
auf dieser unsicheren basis müssen bund
und länder morgen entscheiden wie es
weitergeht dass sie die einschränkungen
verlängern scheint sicher offen ist ob
sie sie auch verschärfen
im gespräch ist offenbar eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre für unternehmen könnte es
schärfere vorgaben für mehr home office
geben und auch eine
ffp zwei masken pflicht in bussen und
bahnen steht im raum
nicole diekmann berichtet das kanzleramt
im zeichen der pandemie heute morgen
traf sich das corona kabinett am frühen
abend findet eine expertinnen anhörung
statt hauptthema hoch ansteckende virus
mutationen gezielt nach ihnen zu suchen
dazu sind die labors nun verpflichtet
mehr ansteckung heißt eben dann mehr
schwer und schwerst kranke deswegen ist
es wichtig die ausbreitung dieser
mutation zu verhindern
das machen wir durch testen durch die
einreise verordnung das impfen der
ältesten und der pflege
heimbewohnerinnen und -bewohner und
jetzt auch durch diese strukturierte
corona virus syriens sowie lienz auf
deutsch überwachung also ein teil der
strategie im kampf gegen das virus wohl
auch eine verlängerung des schattens
daran zweifelt kaum noch jemand beim
thema verschärfungen aber zurückhaltung
ich bin nicht dafür dass wir die ft2
maske verpflichtend überall einführen
ich bin aber dafür dass die
bundesregierung alle bürgerinnen und
bürger mit der ft2 maske ausstatte
schleswig-holstein grundsätzlich ja man
brauche eine langzeitstrategie was
glaube ich viele menschen ein bisschen
frustriert wäre das gar keine
perspektive gesehen wird sondern dass
man immer wieder eine neue konferenz
macht und dann immer wieder einfache
maßnahmen verlängert oder auch
verschärft werden die opposition
zwischen konkreten forderungen und
fundamental ablehnung merkels mega
locker und wird eine megakatastrophe
egal was konkret am ende kommt wir haben
die möglichkeit dass etwa 40 prozent
aller beschäftigten in den büros im home
office arbeiten und ist sind nach zahlen
der letzten woche 14 prozent selbst im
ersten block da unten waren wir besser
also es gibt noch weitere potenziale
berlin im zeichen der pandemie morgen
geht es in die nächste beratungsrunde ja
immer wieder eine neue konferenz theo
koll in berlin jetzt haben wir ja schon
etliche erlebt was es morgen die große
herausforderung
nun die grosse herausforderung morgen
wird sein dass es eine sichtbare und
eine unsichtbare entwicklung gibt und
die entscheidungen müssen er auf
grundlage der unsichtbaren
regelung getroffen werden einerseits
gehen durch die aktuellen maßnahmen wie
haben sie eben gehört die
infektionszahlen langsam runter
andererseits aber könnte sich darunter
eine exponentielle anstieg der mutierten
viren verbergen
das ist genauso in irland passiert da
deutschland aber noch viel zu wenig weiß
für die hiesige verbreitung dieser
deutlich an stecken drin viren und die
politische bremsspur mindestens eine
woche beträgt zwischen erkenntnis und
umsetzung von maßnahmen deshalb steht
die politik jetzt vor der
herausforderung ohne genaue erkenntnisse
quasi vorsorglich auf diese neue gefahr
zu reagieren zur stunde läuft eine
expertenanhörung zu den virus mutationen
auch das dürfte dann die morgigen
entscheidungen mit beeinflussen
information live aus berlin vielen dank
theo koll bayern geht in sachen ffp zwei
masken schon einen schritt weiter die
sind dort seit heute pflicht im
öffentlichen nahverkehr und in
geschäften
der vorteil dieser masken sie schützen
nicht nur das gegenüber besser sondern
auch einen selbst vorausgesetzt sie
sitzen richtig der nachteil ffp zwei
masken sind relativ teuer
erst recht für ein einmal produkt aus
münchen bringt ist heute morgen in
münchen fast alle tragen in den
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln nun die
hier vorgeschriebenen zwei masken jede
maßnahme
daher wirken sollte jeder mitmachen ich
denke dass diese in assen genau
ausgerechnet zumal auch diese maske ja
geld kostet der preis für eine sp2 maske
bis zu 5 euro für bedürftige hat der
freistaat deshalb 2,5 millionen
kostenlose masken angekündigt die
verteilung aber bedauern im landkreis
miesbach rechnen sie mit einer ersten
lieferung morgen mittag nur weil sie
selbst masken auf lager hatten können
sie schon jetzt mit dem versand beginnen
idealerweise gehen vielleicht noch heute
aber spätestens dann morgen am dienstag
die masken per post an die bedürftigen
raus deswegen gibt es in bayern diese
woche auch keine strafen wenn noch
andere masken getragen werden
experten fürchten dass der erhoffte
effekt ausbleibt weil die größte
ansteckungsgefahr nach wie vor dort
lauert wo niemand
eine maske auf hat zudem würden viele
die ffb zwei masken falsch tragen
der tragende muss darin geschult werden
wie die maske dichte sitzt und zum
beispiel können bartträger gar keine
dicht sitzenden fb2 maske tragen weil in
der regel längere bärte dazu führen dass
die maske dem gesicht gar nicht voll an
geformt werden kann frühestens in zehn
tagen können die bayerischen
infektionszahlen belegen wie viel die
neuen maßnahmen in geschäften und den
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln tatsächlich
bringen
in der pandemie sollen die kinder nicht
zur schule oder in die kita gehen die
eltern müssen aufpassen und werden
unterstützt wenn sie deswegen nicht
arbeiten können
auch der bundesrat hat jetzt zugestimmt
das kinderkrankengeld auszuweiten jeder
elternteil kann nun pro kind 20 tage in
anspruch nehmen
statt bisher zehn gezahlt werden
höchstens 112 euro pro tag
die große mehrheit der bundesbürger 67
prozent wollen sich gegen korona impfen
lassen
das sind die aktuellen zahlen des zdf
politbarometers 10 prozent wollen das
auf gar keinen fall tun
22 prozent sind unsicher mit
flugblättern versuchen corona leugner
bundesweit zweifel zu säen die
ärztekammer warnt vor gefährlicher
desinformationen anna bruder berichtet
es ist schon das zweite mal dass
benedikt cordi aus bingen solche flyer
aus seinem briefkasten fischte
flugblätter die die korona pandemie als
fake bezeichnen und angst vor der
impfung schüren war zum zunächst man
natürlich überrascht weil ich gedacht
habe
ob das ist natürlich das tages füllende
thema und wir warten alle auf den
impfstoff und jetzt kommt er genau die
entgegengesetzte aussagen ist ein
bisschen merkwürdig
die verfasser sind gegner von corona
maßnahmen warnen vor impfschäden und
toten durch impfung
die landesärztekammer rheinland-pfalz
spricht von gefährlicher
falschinformation und warnt vor
gruppierungen wie den sogenannten ärzten
für aufklärung
sie kommen daher mit ihrem namen mit
ihrer profession und haben natürlich
aufgrund dieses umstands sofort gehör
aber das was da steht ist schlichtweg
gefährlich
recherchen von journalistinnen von
korrektiv hamm ergeben es ist eine
bundesweite desinformationskampagne die
flyer wurden in den vergangenen wochen
in allen bundesländern verteilt wie sich
die initiativen finanzieren auf diese
anfrage gab es keine klaren antworten
das ziel menschen auch außerhalb des
internets zu erreichen was gedruckt ist
für viele ältere menschen glaube ich
einfach sehr glaubwürdig und natürlich
ist das eine sehr große gefahr dass
gerade die die irgendwie am meisten
gefährdet sind vielleicht dadurch
zweifel haben an der pandemie und dann
in maßnahmen zur bekämpfung benedikt
totti hat den flyer entsorgt doch die
gefahr bleibt dass andere ihn ernst
nehmen
antworten auf offene fragen zur corona
impfung gibt es in einem wiso spezial
direkt nach uns in die schweiz dort hat
die regierung nach langem zögern die
korona maßnahmen verschärft
aus sorge vor einer ausbreitung der
britischen variante des virus
insgesamt gibt es in der schweiz bisher
fast 500.000 infizierte und mehr als
8000 tote ab heute bleiben wie bei uns
alle geschäfte zu die keine güter des
täglichen bedarfs verkaufen
zudem müssen arbeitgeber wo immer es
geht home office anordnen andreas linke
berichtet
kaffee am morgen aber jetzt in der
eigenen küche neben dem laptop oliver
bolanz ist verlagsleiter in basel
er kommt der neuen pflicht zum home
office nach und spürt dass sich in der
schweiz die regeln verschärfen
home office pflicht ist natürlich schon
mal was anderes wie geheim bleibt
insofern finde ich jetzt schon
einschneidend gern schweizer strassen
und plätze wie ihren basel deutlich
leerer als sonst treffen mit maximal
fünf personen so die neuen regeln gastro
und freizeitbetriebe zu ebenso läden mit
ausnahme des täglichen bedarfs für
friseure gilt diese ausnahme anders als
in deutschland und auch für blumenläden
ich verstehe vieles nicht da sind noch
einige geschäfte offen die ich nicht
bräuchte es ist ein politik und
strategiewechsel bei den eidgenossen
bisherige corona maßnahmen waren
deutlich weniger streng als etwa in
deutschland wegen der in die skigebiete
eingeschleppten nun virusvariante und
deren heftiger folgen in england und
irland sieht sich nun auch die schweizer
regierung unter druck sie will
vorsorglich handeln wir haben für das
erste mal in dieser pandemie dieses
wissensvorsprung und
informationsvorsprung das uns erlaubt
wirklich richtige richtig aber richtigen
moment zu handeln die skigebiete
allerdings bleiben offen sport im freien
sei dass daran will die alpen nation
zunächst festhalten
alexej nawalny muss in russland 30 tage
lang ins gefängnis und die empörung im
westen ist groß vor allem wegen des
umgangs mittlerweile als der
putin-kritiker gestern aus deutschland
zurückkehrte wurde sein flug umgeleitet
festnahme am pass schalter des einen
moskauer flughafens während seine
anhänger ihm wenige kilometer weiter an
einem anderen begrüßen wollten
und schon am morgen danach einem
blitzverfahren aus moskau für begangen
dass das ein fairer prozess war glaub
von ihnen hier niemand
anhänger von alexei navalny fordern vor
einer polizeiwache im norden moskaus die
freilassung des kreml-kritikers mit
alexei navalny geschehen regelmäßig
dinge die außerhalb der gängigen praxis
und außerhalb der gesetzeslage liegen
woraufhin ich mich an den europäischen
gerichtshof wenden und jedes mal wird
uns dann bestätigt dass unsere richter
geltendes recht beugen
nachdem dabei gestern am moskauer
flughafen festgenommen wird weiß die
ganze nacht lang niemand wohin er
gebracht wurde
seine anwälte dürfen erst heute mittag
zu ihrem mandanten kurz danach geht
dieses video von navalny online
keine ahnung was hier abläuft vor genau
einer minute hat man mich aus der zelle
geholt um eine anwältin zu treffen
ein eilverfahren auf der polizeistation
keine möglichkeit der anwälte sich
darauf vorzubereiten
aussenminister maas sieht heute die zeit
gekommen russland an seine
internationalen verpflichtungen zur
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu erinnern und
diese prinzipien müssen auch angewandt
werden was für uns nichts anderes
bedeutet als dass herr navalny
unverzüglich freigelassen wird kritik am
moskauer vorgehen kommt auch aus der eu
den usa und der eu an russlands
außenminister prallt sie ab die
westlichen politiker freuen sich so weil
sie so die aufmerksamkeit von der großen
krise ablenken können der sich das
liberale entwicklungsmodell für samstag
ruft alexej nawalny zu straßenprotesten
auf
denn das sei es so der kreml-kritiker
bevor sich die mächtigen in ihren
bunkern am meisten fürchten die us
hauptstadt gleicht einer festung
übermorgen wird joe biden als neuer
präsident vereidigt aus sorge vor
gewaltsamen ausschreitungen durch trump
anhänger wurden die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen in washington
massiv verstärkt das kapitol ist
großräumig abgeriegelt rund um die
amtseinführung sind 25.000
nationalgardisten im einsatz
tunesien ist das einzige land dem
während des arabischen frühlings ein
übergang zur demokratie gelungen ist
korruption und schlechte wirtschaftslage
aber plagen tunesien weiter
dazu kommt das treibt seit mehreren
tagen vor allem junge leute auf die
straße
dabei gab es zusammenstöße mit der
polizei die nun von der armee
unterstützt wird mehr als 600 menschen
wurden festgenommen
britischer fisch vergammelt in lastern
weil der weg von großbritannien nach
europa für die spediteure schon mal
mehrere tage dauert das ist die realität
nach dem wechsel im ganzen land klagen
viele unternehmen über neue
bürokratische hürden die fischer bringt
das auf die palme
normalerweise fahren sie meeresfrüchte
von schottland in die eu heute aber
protestierten diese fernfahrer im
londoner regierungsviertel
der premier hatte der fischereiindustrie
mit dem brad pitt die kontrolle über die
britischen gewässer versprochen nun aber
steckt ihre ware an der grenze fest wenn
es so weitergeht werden unternehmen
pleite gehen das würde mich den job
kosten
seitdem großbritannien den binnenmarkt
verlassen hat müssen tierische produkte
und lebend lieferungen an den eu grenzen
kontrolliert werden dort aber fehlt es
an zollbeamten oder auch an den
richtigen formularen das überlebt so
manches schalentier nicht wir haben
vergangene woche eine lieferung nach
europa geschickt die hat fünf tage
gebraucht da war alles tot und
vergammelt das ist jetzt die zweite
woche in der wir nicht in unseren
größten markt verkaufen können
ein drittel der schottischen flotte
fährt gerade gar nicht mehr raus wozu
auch wenn man den fang nicht los wird
dieser betrieb stellt auf gefrorenes um
hat aber angst langfristig kunden in der
eu zu verlieren
zur verteidigung der misere führte ein
leidenschaftlicher dragset anhänger den
seelenzustand der tiere an
der punkt ist wir haben unsere fische
zurück sie sind jetzt britisch und der
fall besser und glücklicher hohn in den
ohren der leidtragenden fischer denen
bietet die regierung jetzt zwar 25
millionen euro entschädigung an
doch das ist ein schwacher trost groß
waren ihre hoffnungen auf dem brett
traurig ist die realität
und jetzt haben wir ein norbert d wn
gestern ja die zwangspause für das
deutsche team nachdem das spiel gegen
kap verde wegen kroner fällen abgesagt
wurde
die afrikanische mannschaft ist heute
abgereist jetzt ist die dhb auswahl heiß
auf die partie morgen gegen ungarn es
geht um den gruppensieg
ein überzeugendes spiel das ziel der
deutschen gegen ungarn eine entscheidung
hat der bundestrainer bereits verkündet
wolf beginnt dem tor die gegner erwarten
sie auf augenhöhe körperliche mannschaft
haben große starke spieler da im
innenblock die dann über die halbe
kommen und viele bewohner von hinten
nehmen das turnier bestimmt durch viele
hygienemaßnahmen die sorge dass sich
ungarische spieler im ersten
vorrundenspiel infiziert haben könnten
gering
das spielt jetzt gegen gehabt weil dafür
ungarn ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her
die wollen auch immer wieder getestet
eklig wir werden die täglich getestet
von daher können uns jetzt voll auf das
sportliche konzentrieren bleibt die
hoffnung dass sich die spieler in
ägypten noch lange mit dem spielgerät
beschäftigten werden und das spiel
deutschland ungarn morgen abend live bei
uns im zdf ab 20 15
der eishockey weltverband hat mit
ausrichter belarus die weltmeisterschaft
in diesem jahr entzogen
aus sicherheitsgründen wie es heißt
zuletzt hatten die hauptsponsoren des
turniers druck auf den verband gemacht
wegen der politischen lage im bilde russ
zurwonne globe 25 einhand segler haben
bei ihrer weltumrundung zum zweiten mal
den äquator überquert damit beginnt
sozusagen der final sprint der deutsche
boris herrmann in aussichtsreicher
position
tag 71 ruppige see und kaum schlaf in
den letzten 12 stunden boris herrmann
hat richtig gut zu tun aber der bruch
zeigt schon mal richtung europa und
hermann wird schneller den äquator
überquert er als dritter sein boot dc
explorer ist das schnellste der
spitzengruppe in führung der franzose
charlie dollar hermann ist zurzeit
sechster
aber die experten trauen ihm sogar den
sieg zu 5000 kilometer haben die segler
noch vor sich und das rennen ist
spannend wie ein guter krimi mit 10 12
tage wird es noch dauern bis sie in
frankreich am ziel ankommen das wetter
bietet regen schnee und sturm mehr dazu
hat gleich osten terry
um viertel vor zehn freut sich marietta
slomka auf sie im heute journal
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen entspannten
montagabend bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen